Ryan let's talk about the road to
syndicates
so we're talking about battlefield
hardline after you earn your initial
weapons there are these syndicate class
of weapons and when you go into battle
log you just get some big old mystery
marks as to what you have to do to get
your syndicate guns yup that's right
either you have to hope that you're
gonna find out just by chance or you can
go to Reddit and have a look at the
requirements let's talk about the class
of pistols and SMGs you have to get to
actually even get to the point where you
can get to unlocking syndicate weapons
and that's the assignment to weapon
system right so basically if you're
looking to get the syndicate rifles
along the way you will have to unlock
the pistols and there's four of them
there's one for each class and those are
the Glock 17 for the operator the 410
jury for mechanic the bald eagle for the
enforcer and the mac-10 for professional
Iran what was your favorite unlock for
the level 2 assignments well the bald
eagle is very easily one of the most
powerful weapons in game and I think in
general the enforcer class is doesn't
have the best weapon options so the bald
eagle is kind of a breath of fresh air
for the class it's hugely powerful as an
8-round mag it can drop a guy in 2 shots
up to 30 metres away which means you can
take down 4 enemies before reloading so
is that the first one you'd recommend
going for I would especially again
because of the enforcer is kind of a
ho-hum class to begin with and it's not
that hard to get it's essentially
absorbing damage with your shield and
some shotgun kills yeah it's a just a
handful of shotgun kills and then a
certain amount of damage with the shield
it's like 250 points of damage which you
can do in a couple of matches and just
remind people you have to do all of
these in order to even unlock the
syndicate assignments correct every
single one of these two your two
assignments for the classes you have to
do before you can even
in to unlock do the unlocks risen so if
the bald eagle is the easiest one to get
what do you think's the hardest the
hardest one to acquire is the mac-10 for
the professional class it's a machine
pistol comes of the suppressor comes
with a stock so it starts out pretty
well kitted yeah it can empty a magazine
in a heartbeat and it's super fun as far
as is it better than what already exists
in the class I don't know if that's true
like I think that the g18 once you tame
it with a compensator is probably the
go-to for the professional class but for
style points the mac-10 just too damn
cool to put them another thing is a
pretty crazy rate of fire like I've
noticed it kicks and it has a high rate
of fire so you pretty much can get one
maybe two guys if they're lined up but
other than that you're reloading pretty
much you're gonna spend that magazine on
one guy if you're lucky too what was
difficult about that assignment the
problem with that assignment is that you
need five camera coins and by the way if
you're moving on to syndicate you're
going to need 15 more is the camera
coins are 10 kills by teammates of
enemies that have been spotted by your
camera that sounds way out of your
control it is so far out of your control
it's ridiculous one kind of simple tip
is that you want to put your cameras in
places where there is going to be a lot
of foot traffic but not a lot of grenade
spam so maps that are a little bit wider
open like heist on Everglades or Blood
Money on downtown so let's talk about
the other two weapons that you were not
as thrilled about starting with the
Glock 17 unlock for the operator
so the g17 is fine it's basically just a
semi-automatic version of the G 18 and I
just don't think there's anything
special about it considering that the
operator class has some of the most
dominant weapons in the game for the
primary I think it's okay the secondary
is a little weak but I would personally
stick to the cz-75 if I'm a criminal and
probably the p226 as a cop and the last
assignment to weapons the interesting
410 jury basically it's a shotgun pistol
yeah it's got a 5 round cylinder it's a
shotgun pistol
has probably hands down the coolest
reload animation in the entire game yeah
he's holding like three shells in one
hand he like puts back in and it's also
got the coolest rare animation which we
haven't personally captured but it's out
there you can google it there's a 1 in
10,000 on an emptied something like that
honestly I was not at all pleased with
the weapon I think the first time I took
it out I got a bunch of kills I liked it
but then the more I started using it I
you know it takes on average 3 shots to
kill somebody you only get 5 in the
cylinder so you're doing you're taking
out one and a half guys it's a kind of
an OK finisher but it's range is so
short that getting a copy loading a lot
exactly and it's just I would stick to
the 357 or the 44 depending on what
factional fighting the one positive
thing about the fort injury is actually
apparently the devs have already taken
note and it's gonna get a buff in the
next patch so now you've completed all
the prerequisites for syndicate how do
you feel in general about this system of
you know like you have to unlock these
weapons to get to those weapons I like
this system because there's definitely
like a sort of skill requirement it has
the assignments which Battlelog is a
complete nightmare to figure out what
you're supposed to do to complete
assignments but the assignments
themselves are somewhat interesting
they're not as exciting as titanfall
which kind of got you to like play
totally differently when you went for
challenges but it is an interesting way
of rewarding you for making that effort
final question are you saving up 10
million dollars for your masks I am NOT
going to save up 10 million dollars my
masks I will I will buy stupid silver
battle packs before that happens all
right well thanks for stopping by and
giving us your short impressions of
assignment 2 weapons and as always for
more coverage of battlefield hardline
stay tuned to game's calm
you